A BLACK HAWK HELICOPTER DOWN IN
WESTERN IRAQ.
WE WILL BRING YOU MORE DETAILS
AS WE GET THEM HERE ON FOX NEWS.
THE PROSPECTIVE HEAD OF ONE OF
THE COUNTRY'S LEADING
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AS RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THIS FALL'S
MIDTERM ELECTIONS WILL CONTINUE
UNLESS CHANGES ARE MADE.
HE IS ALSO A WARNING AGAINST
OTHER BAD INTENTIONS FROM THE
KREMLIN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE TELLS US
MORE.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S CHOICE TO
HEAD THE NATIONAL SECURITY
AGENCY SAID THE RUSSIANS ARE
ADDED AGAIN.
>> WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT THAT RUSSIA
INTERFERED IN THE ELECTIONS?
IN LIGHT OF THEIR SUCCESS IN
THOSE EFFORTS, DO YOU EXPECT
FURTHER INTERFERENCE BY RUSSIA?
>> MR. VICE CHAIRMAN, I AGREE
WITH THE 2017 ASSESSMENT.
>> THAT STATEMENT APPEARS TO PUT
GENERAL NAKASONE AT ODDS WITH
HOUSE COMMITTEE REPUBLICANS ARE
FOUND INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
CONCLUDE RUSSIANS ELECTION
INTERFERENCE WAS DESIGNED TO
HELP CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP.
WITH SURVEILLANCE UNDER SCRUTINY
BY REPUBLICANS, NAKASONE IS
PRESSED BY DEMOCRATS.
>> YOU ARE ASKED TO AVOID THE
COURT BASED ON SOME KIND OF
SECRET LEGAL ANALYSIS.
>> I WOULD CONSULT WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND HOW THAT
DISCUSSION.
I WOULD FOLLOW THE LAW AND
ENSURE THAT THE AGENCY FOLLOWS
THE LAW.
>> WITH SANCTIONS IMPOSED ON
RUSSIA, LAWMAKERS WANTED MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE POSSIBLE
COMPROMISE OF
COMPUTER-CONTROLLED NETWORKS >>
THE ELECTRIC GRID IS NOT ONLY
VULNERABLE BUT FROM PUBLIC
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PA
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PT
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PM
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PL
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PA
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PE
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PI
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PN
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PS
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO PE
REPORTS, THERE ARE EFFORTS TO P.
>> SENATOR, THE ENTIRE DEFENSE
OF OUR ELECTRIC SYSTEM IS OF
GREAT CONCERN TO ME.
>> THE COMMITTEES REPUBLICAN
CHAIRMAN SAID LAWMAKERS WOULD
MOVE QUICKLY TO CONFIRM THE
GENERAL.
>> I THINK YOU ARE THE RIGHT
PERSON AT THE RIGHT TIME.
I THINK YOUR ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE TECHNICAL
LOGICAL CHANGES IN ASSET TO YOU
OR A LIABILITY.
>> THE NOMINEE SAID SMARTPHONE
TRACKING SOFTWARE AND FITBIT
TECHNOLOGY COMPOSE OPERATIONAL
SECURITY THREATS.